you've all seen the famous image of
Jimmy Butler exhausted floating around
the internet but do you remember the
actual moment from the 2020 finals where
Jimmy rested just 49 seconds that saved
the Heat season Jimmy Butler was a beast
during the bubble 2020 playoffs
averaging 22 points six and a half
rebounds and six assists per game Butler
let the heat all the way to the NBA
finals making it their sixth finals
appearance in this Century fast forward
to game five of the series it was a Do
or Die situation for the Heat and even
though he barely had legs Jimmy was not
going down without a fight Butler played
47 out of 48 minutes notching a 35-point
triple-double while going shot for shot
with LeBron who had 40 on his own he
literally rested for less than a minute
in the entire game with 16.8 seconds
left in the game and the heat down 108
to 107 Jimmy was fouled Jimmy walked
over to the Baseline and bent over to
catch his breath and that's when this
iconic image was taken he got back up
and sank two free throws to give Miami
the lead and the heat went on to force a
game six the image took over the
Internet becoming another addition to
Jimmy's viral meme collection